[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler pierre
chasse fréon direct a délégué général de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes bonsoir pierre
chasserait merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau avec nous également
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
chèque carburant baisse des taxes
bouclier ce sont toutes ces pistes dont
on parle tous les jours dans les médias
qui sont étudiées par le gouvernement
français face à la hausse des prix des
des carburants bout pierre chasserez le
spécialiste de l'automobiliste des
automobilistes vous espérez quelle
mesure qu'ils sortent du chapeau 2 de
jean castex dans la soirée ou demain
probablement
écouter essayer de rester cohérent étant
donné que le projet de baisse de lait
tombé à cinq et demi pour ce temps c'est
la mesure de 40 millions
d'automobilistes qu'on avait soufflé à
l'oreille des candidats qui a d'abord
été reprises par anne hidalgo puis
marine le pen puis eric ciotti puis eric
zemmour et pour finir je prends un autre
candidat tu me pardonneras vu que c'est
notre proposition je vais soutenir notre
proposition vous ne voudrez pas la
baisse de la tva à 5,5 est la bête l'été
à verre à 5,5 certes qui est tout de
même on toque blanche maison la solution
peut-être là alors la plus juste
socialement mais la plus coûteuse aussi
pour l'état quand on sait que alors on
en parlera avec kercha srecki qui n'est
pas d'accord mais pourtant c'est ce que
on lit un petit peu partout donc votre
réponse en intéressera tout le banc
maison est ce que en tout cas dans cette
approche le gouvernement est contraint
par plusieurs facteurs si j'ose dire
dans la classe politique française et
ceux qui souhaitent une mesure ciblée
pour aider l'infirmière qui a besoin de
circuler en automobile dans la campagne
où tous les gens qui ont absolument
besoin de décence pour pour faire leur
eau leur métier pour pour circuler pour
survivre et puis ceux qui considèrent
qu'ils que c'est trop compliqué que dans
le fond on n'a pas
les fichiers qui permettent de faire
cela et qu'il vaut mieux prendre en
effet une mesure uniforme et par
conséquent agir par le biais de la
fiscalité soit la tva soit l'autre taxe
taxe bien français la taxe intérieure
sur
l'aller les produits les produits
énergétiques là qui est une taxe assez
élevé qui est d'ailleurs partagée entre
les collectivités territoriales une
petite fraction va à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et le reste va
à l'état donc sur le bio sur le plan
fiscal il ya deux possibilités il ya la
tva et cette taxe spécifique française
est plus élevé que la tva a d'ailleurs
et puis il ya les mesures ciblées alors
je crois que la décision n'est
probablement pas encore prise et que le
président de la république se réserve
peut-être de prendre la température à à
bruxelles demain au conseil européen
pour voir ce que les uns et les autres
vont dire avant de prendre sa décision
même si dans son for intérieur il sait
dans quelle direction il va on va
évidemment parler avec 12 de cet aspect
international qui a son importance
évidemment dans ce dossier puisque c'est
encore repris des pompes et de l'énergie
va au-delà évidemment de la france il ya
certaines contraintes européennes pierre
chats seraient alors les taxes à la vous
vous montriez parce qu on lit très
précisément jeu quand je lisais ce matin
chez nos confrères du parisien si on
augmente notion réduit de 2,1 centimes à
la pompe ça fait 500 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en moins dans les
caisses de de l'étal vrai ou faux alors
vous savez je vais vous expliquer le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a une
majorité de journalistes qui répète ce
qu'un ministre et qui ne vérifie pas en
fait en économie il y a deux axes il ya
le trop perçu et le manque à gagner ces
deux choses différentes aujourd'hui les
taxes sur les carburants sont au plus
fort jamais dans l'histoire de france
nous n'avons connu autant de taxes sur
les carburants jamais nous sommes sa
sentiers sur les prix à la pompe au
dessus de ce qui était budgété par le
gouvernement alors ensuite c'est un
calcul les taxes et 60% ont fait 60 % de
7 centimes il reste une dizaine de
centimes c'est à dire que nous sommes
dans une situation où l'état chaque jour
perçoit 10 centimes de trop perçus sur
les taxes autrement dit un centime égale
500 mignon là dessus il a raison mille
et brunel bruno le maire mais ce qu'il a
oublié de dire c'est que on n'est pas
dans une situation où si on baisse les
textes ya un taxi un manque à gagner
pour l'état on est dans une situation où
on est dix centimes au-dessus on
ponctionne on braque c'est un hold up on
braque les automobilistes à hauteur de 5
milliards de trop chaque année par
rapport à ce qui est budgétée nous
sommes dans une situation de trop perçu
alors on va regarder justement les
prières en france mais aussi au niveau
européen qui sont très haut vous voyez
la france évidemment 1,63 ça va jusqu'à
1,60 cette embellie de 200 plants en
allemagne en italie aux pays-bas c'est
encore pire que le blanchemaison on le
constate parce qu'on en parle peut-être
pas toujours assez ce combien il est
vraiment mondial européen quelle marge
de manoeuvre au niveau de l'europe est
ce que c'est sur le sol vieillit là
qu'il faut jouer et comme on le sait le
prix de l'essence à la pompe et il est
constitué par un tiers qui représentent
le coût de la production pétrolière
une quantité très faible qui est le coût
du raffinage de à deux et demi pour cent
le raffinage c'est pas très rentable cet
avis pour cent la distribution pour la
mise à disposition dans les stations
service et puis le reste en effet ce
sont les taxes
les taxes c'est une une c'est une part
très importante des prix à la pompe
puisqu'il ya la tva au prix
naturellement la tva au taux normal de
20% et puis cette fameuse taxe
intérieure sur la consommation
énergétique qui est réparti entre trois
parties prenantes est l'une des parties
prenantes même si c'est dans une faible
mesure c'est le ministère de la
transition énergétique
parce que en effet il ya une autre
considération qu'il faut prendre en
compte il ya bien sûr l'intérêt du
consommateur il ya l'intérêt du budget
de l'état mais il ya aussi la transition
énergétique et l'idée est quand même que
à long terme on doit réduire la
consommation d'essence et que par
conséquent tout ce qui constitue à coup
tout ce qui consiste à aller et le prix
de l'essence ne va pas dans ce sens
'cependant d'ailleurs pour ça qu'un
certain nombre de nos partenaires
européens ont des prix de l'essence qui
sont plus élus encore en france donc
cette discussion elle a lieu
actuellement entre différents membres du
gouvernement est en effet le président
de la république doit arbitrer
probablement après avoir entendu ce que
vont dire ses collègues à bruxelles
demain ce qu'on va dire la commission
mais à bruxelles brussels la ii n'a pas
de pouvoir sur ce sur ce sujet puisque
tout ce qui est fiscal et de compétences
nationales et pour le reste ça dépend
des grandes compagnies pétrolières et
pierre chasserait on voit s'afficher à
l'écran cet axe ils représentent 50 à 70
pensant les prix du carburant dans
l'ensemble des pays membres de l'union
européenne ça nous inspire quoi à vous
j'ai pas pour habitude de regarder se
passe ailleurs en j'habite dans le pays
qui pratiquent le plus fort taux de
fiscalité sur ces habitants moi je vous
le tenez aussi dépendant de de l'europe
dans ce cas précis de figure
je ne regarde pas si ce qui est appliqué
regardez l'allemagne des développe 9
milliards pour les énergies pour les
habitants tout globale et encore il ya
encore les annonces sur les carburants
nous en france on n'a pas débloqué neuf
milliards que je sache donc pour
l'instant on va s'occuper d'un hobbit et
me rappellent qu'ils emportaient le
semaine on implorait les automobilistes
de partir en france sur littoral pour
relancer le commerce relancer la
consommation développer le taux de
croissance du pays qui est basé sur la
consommation et donc le pib donc ce que
je joue là où je m'étonne aujourd'hui
c'est que la bobologie a atteint nos
ministres et que maintenant nous
pointent du doigt en disant on va quand
même pas aider ceux qui partent on les
suivait à la mer bon quand on entend des
propos aussi aussi condescendants de la
farb minière fois le fameux 4 4 en
direction de deauville effectivement on
l'a entendu beaucoup ces derniers jours
dans les médias vous trouvez ça injuste
mais non c'est pas injuste c'est bio
c'est à dire que c'est juste notre
crayon public qu'on est bête
donc je m'inquiète pas même un on est
ministre de l'économie et des finances
et qu'on a pris pour habitude de pointer
du doigt des français en les montrant du
doigt en les stigmatisant et on ne les
faisant passer pour des imbéciles ça en
dit long quand même sur ce les personnes
qui sont à la tête de deux pays moi je
me dis que les manuels aujourd'hui est
atteint du syndrome du poisson ou c'est
à dire qu'il a fait trois fois dans
l'elysée depuis maintenant trois ans et
il a oublié ce qui s'est passé en 2010
alors faut arrêter de compter les
moutons d'elle et se dire que si demain
il ya gilet jaune là ça va coûter de
l'argent à la france et là ça sera du
manque à gagner pas du trop-perçu
deuxième petit considérons maintenant
moi je quand même 1 43 ans a fait tout
pour alzheimer
on voit sourire
on peut simplement soutenir une autre
argumentation est ce qu'on veut faire
une mesure sociale est ce qu'on veut
faire une mesure politique est ce qu'on
veut faire une mesure économique alors
effectivement la mesure sociale
semble-t-il très difficile à pratiquer
parce que quelles seraient les
bénéficiaires exactement on risquerait
d'ailleurs dans l'oublié la mesure
uniforme et donc fiscale est en effet
assez séduisant cela dit on a montré que
ça n'a pas beaucoup relancer la
consommation dans les stations
balnéaires et en effet l'argument disant
on fait un cadeau à tout le monde est un
argument qui probablement sera reprochée
au gouvernement par la gauche peut-être
par la droite aussi est en tout cas par
les écologistes donc la défie la
décision est très difficile à prendre
pour le pour le pour le président d'ifil
d'ici demain pierre je serai je m'envoie
faire des noms long avec la tête non
parce que je regarde l'échiquier
politique mais perçoit cas droit qu'on
est favorable à la baisse des taxes
michel barnier vient d'annoncer je
m'aperçois qu'anne hidalgo était la
première à parler de la baisse des taxes
donc non il ya unanimité si on prend du
côté de la droite à la droite de la
droite du côté d'eric zemmour de marine
le pen on est favorable à la baisse des
taxes non non en fait il est une seule
personne en france qui est défavorable à
la baisse des taxes et les écologistes
mais les écologistes c'est qui
ces personnes en train de prendre des
mesures en la population c'est ça le
principe 95 donc moins besoin de
carburant dans pour arrêter un petit peu
de céder à ces chantages vers moi j'ai
l'impression que les verts ils sont
surtout très gris quand ma main et quand
il quand il s'agit de chercher des
arguments le donc ça c'est une constante
non non ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est
de passer à l'action arrêté un petit peu
et se dire que quand on est président de
la république on est élu par les
français aujourd'hui on pensait qu'ils
ont portés manuel macron à la tête de ce
pays ont souhaité souhaite une baisse
des taxes sur le carburant dont acte
c'est un braquage l'entendre % de taxes
comment peut-on accepter de nos pour
qu'un produit soit taxée à hauteur de
60% et l'argument écologique faut
arrêter faut arrêter les forêts achète
lévis on leur propose si demain on
propose aux français un véhicule
économique électrique avec des pommes
des bornes de recharge pas cher qui vont
faire quoi les français bayrou l'acheter
parce que si demain de coluche 1 si on
vous propose deux paquets de lessive
contre un paquet de lessive ah bon je
convie les deux paquets c'est comme ça
donc soyons un petit peu pragmatique
arrêtons de faire des belles phrases
pour plaire à gripen berg à glasgow pour
la coop 26 ça franchement et n'importe
quoi commençons à faire aux politiques
ou les français avant de se paie quand
même d'une minorité de marginaux qui
aujourd'hui plus le pays la bobologie
c'est le cancer de la france comme dans
le présent qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre
demain de ce sommet à bruxelles qui va
tenter de voir comment effectivement
joué sur ses records de prix dans toute
l'europe parce que certes on est en
france mais ça concerne la vue sur ce
graphique tout cela je te plaît avant
tout les tous les états membres ont pas
répondre à ce problème d'abord à court
terme c'est qu'en effet il ya un pic des
prix de l'essence et que ça pose un
problème en effet politique qui dié qui
risque fort de durer oui enfin on dit
que ça va durer peut-être six mois il se
trouve que comme par hasard ça
correspond à la période électorale parce
que quand même à long terme tout le
monde pense que et d'ailleurs les
compagnies pétrolières elles-mêmes se
diversifie les compagnies pétrolières
n'investissent plus dans le pétrole la
v6 plus le gave elle investit dans les
énergies renouvelables total multiplie
les actions dans l'énergie renouvelable
ça veut dire qu'à long terme tout le
monde pense qu'il va falloir évoluer
mais en effet à court terme il y a une
pointe à écrêter et il faut en tenir
compte sans doute pour en effet
l'ensemble de la classe moyenne
française donc on a d'espoir pour demain
que ça puisse répercuter de manière
favorable dans d'autres pays également
c'est le président c'est un gouvernement
national qui prendra la décision et
pourra s'appuyer sur tel ou tel argument
et or est évoquée d'évoquer à bruxelles
mais ça n'est pas à bruxelles de prendre
la décision ça ne lui appartient pas
puisque la fiscalité et de compétences
nationales et entendu le piège à serait
justement sur cette durée vous avez bon
espoir que les prix baissent
on le disait à un horizon de six mois me
disais qu'on branche maison
ne vous a pas échappé que suis pas
ministre
mais je me dis que si demain je devais
faire de la politique quand je suis sur
un sujet aussi tendue celui qu'on vit
actuellement dans un contexte où on
arrive trois ans après les gilets jaunes
on a vu quand même notre pays dans un
état même sérieusement amoché où
personne ne veut revivre ça je me dis
qu'il faudrait être quand même
profondément
touché on ne pas qu'on prend on est dans
l'obligation de baisser les taxes donc
la question c'est pas de savoir nous
plier si on fait un chèque carburant si
on fait ceci ou cela en question et
d'agir pour ne pas retrouver notre pays
dans un contexte où deux classes vont
s'opposer d'une aux autres je n'ai pas
envie de voir des laissés pour compte
dans le pass moyenne qui nous touchent
rien quelques automobilistes qui vont
pouvoir moyennant le dossier où ils vont
devoir limite faire la mendicité pour
obtenir 20 euros je ne trouve pas que ce
soit digne d'un état comme la france les
carburants c'est de la mobilité linverse
de la mobilité ça s'appelle le
confinement et le confinement j'ai pas
envie de revenir donc faut savoir si on
veut l'assaut amazon on sait tous qu'il
rêvait produit parce que ça coûte moins
cher et que finalement on n'a pas besoin
de sortir de chez soi et le carburant le
prochain ou alors si on décide d'avoir
un peu
bouge qui vit et qui peut se permettre
des déplacements moi perso ma voiture ou
bien vous savez quoi je vais partir avec
mes enfants en vacances et j'ai pas
honte en suis très fier dans les maisons
vacances bruno le maire ministre des
finances devrait peut-être faire que moi
peut-être que ça lui prendra un petit
peu de souffle en ce moment il va pas
très bien quelle part faisant le mot de
la fin ce que clairement des réformes
plus ambitieuses sur le long terme
seront nécessaires d'ailleurs certaines
seront examinées demain à bruxelles il
faut aller dans le sens évidemment
d'urgence mais au delà aussi sur le
pétrole c'est très difficile puisque le
marché est un marché mondial que les
grandes sociétés pétrolières sont des
sociétés qui agissent sur le marché
mondial et par conséquent le cadre
bruxellois est trop étroit pour ces
sociétés dans conséquent ils pompent des
mesures efficaces ne peuvent pas être
prises ce qui se passe actuellement
c'est que justement au niveau mondial le
prix du pétrole à monter d'ailleurs pour
un bon motif c'est parce que il ya une
reprise économique partout dans le monde
après le coc vidé après le confinement
que qu'on a malheureusement vécu donc
cette reprise en effet induit une
augmentation importante de la demande de
pétrole et l'offre a du mal à suivre
probablement que les stocks n'étaient
pas suffisants il ya peut-être aussi là
une responsabilité des sociétés et des
états pour faire face à cette
augmentation importante de la demande
donc il faut probablement que sur ces
sujets les 27 chefs d'état de
gouvernement peuvent
confort qu'ont concerter leurs points de
vue et prendre des orientations mais
encore une fois il reviendra à chaque
état membre pour l'urgence actuelle de
prendre des mesures nationales et puis
pour le reste et bien qu'on le veuille
ou non ce sont les grandes sociétés
pétrolières et les pays producteurs qui
déterminent l'avenir du marché du marché
pétrolier et qui détermine par
conséquent le prix du pétrole est au
bout du compte le prix à la pompe alors
bien sûr on peut on peut le bc en
baissant les taxes s'abaissera les
revenus des revenus du fisc pourquoi pas
c'est une variable qui probablement
d'ailleurs sera soumise aux électeurs
lors des prochaines élections merci en
tout cas à tous des deux merci que le
blanche les en remercie beaucoup pia
chaufferait d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france